wireless providers t-mobile and Sprint
are planning a twenty six and a half
billion dollar merger t-mobile would
acquire sprint using stock instead of
cash if regulators approve the deal cell
phone customers in the US would be left
with a choice of three national
providers the Gallagher fortune senior
editor at large is with us good morning
good work alright this could mean 100
million subscribers for this joint
company what does it mean for customers
yeah it's a big deal I mean this puts
these numbers three and four together to
really challenge the number one and two
which have a combined market share of
70% between AT&T and Verizon so what the
companies are saying is that this will
you know it's harder to compete they
need this to become you know competitive
especially as there's this incredible
race going on for the next frontier of
Technology which is a 5g networks so for
consumers it's unclear what what's
interesting about this deal is the way
they're positioning it they are
positioning it actually as this is
better value for consumers and this will
be better for the marketplace in general
they're saying that our technology will
be better when it's merged and when we
can invest more they're saying they're
gonna spend a lot they're playing to the
heartstrings of some very topical issues
right now they're saying we're gonna
hire a lot more we are going to help
lead America in the race for 5g so it's
very interesting in fact Sprint CEO says
going from 4G to 5g is like going from
black and white to color TV yeah I'm
ready for I'm ready for it
I know well this is a very big deal I
mean this is what's gonna power the next
generation of all these technologies
we're hearing about everything from
autonomous cars augmented reality
Internet of Things this is coming but
it's incredibly it's a major major
investment this is billions and billions
of dollars and they really needed to
they do they do need to join forces to
be able to better compete they're
talking about creating more jobs put
that in context they are doing all this
new stuff building things that's jobs
but there's a lot of churn right aren't
there always I mean they're gonna have
some overlapping retail stores on the
other hand they say they're gonna push
more into rural areas they're saying
they're gonna save about 6 billion in
operational costs and that they're gonna
spend 40 billion dollars over the next
three years they also make the case
about China which sounds like a message
to the administration which is going to
have to okay
this deal is that how yes these are
these are as you know again like just
playing right to the heartstrings
they're saying that this will be America
first and that this will you know 5g is
something that the White House is
already set as a national priority and
here they can say you know we're not
going to see this with China and they
buy them by them entering the game
combined that will accelerate the the
race towards 5 G's American honors but
there is a Japanese bank that is
involved there isn't in fact masa masa
oshi sign of soft bank which controls
sprit he has wanted this ever since he
took control and parties involved yes
but he did meet with the president right
at right after the election and that I'm
gonna invest fifty billion dollars okay
guys we will see what happens we
Gallagher from fortune always thank you